hi ELO is Elma and me Ki monster and all
of our friends from Sesame Street are
here to deal the wired autocomplete
interview yeah remember we did this
before I do not like the idea of people
searching things about me we are just
answering questions from the internet
then why did I dress up this is a rental
you
[Music]
know what is Sesame Street known for
that's easy magic Zipp zap
cookies cute and adorable Monsters of
course oh did grber say that about Elmo
oh grob's so nice you know he's pretty
cute too wait what singing Friendship
Learning and playing together oh yeah
and yuck where did Sesame Street get its
name you see I was walking down the
Street one day eating a sesame Bagel
when it dawned on me Bagel
Street no no no no wait uh Sesame Street
yeah thank goodness I was not eating a
Pumpernickel loaf it's called Sesame
Street because Snicker doodle Street was
too long didn't fit on the sign is it
too late to call it Snicker doodle
Street like the magical phrase Open
Sesame Sesame Street is a place where
anything can happen where is Sesame
Street at at at what where is Sesame
Street at did we move Why did no one
tell me we moved how am I supposed to
get back home there is Sesame Street
Sesame Street's just where Sesame Street
is that's a difficult question it's a
place where kids want to learn and play
with monsters and fairies and birds and
crouches can come come on by at the
intersection of scram and get lost
what's the next one what is a Sesame
Street lesson oh that's easy ABC's 1 2 3
that's two
lessons
two there you go numbers oh well you
know you know the letter c well it turns
out C is for
cie that's a terrific lesson that it's
okay to be grouchy sometimes or all the
time to show love to one another you
know treat others the way you would like
to be treated that's very important
where is Sesame Street Elmo you're
looking at him where isn't Sesame Street
Elmo he everywhere there he there he
there he there he there you never know
Miss Justin Justin hi would you mind
when you peel the question can you read
it for Elmo because well Elmo can't read
yet sure no problem thank you go for it
what are Elmo's friends names oh um well
let's see Elma has a lot of friends so
there's Abby and Cookie Monster and Big
Bird
and Felix and
and baby SM music Lefty
sler is that it oh afraid he left
somebody out um well they'll be okay
let's see what the next one is Miss
Justine what is Elmo scared of oh what
is Elmo scared of well sometimes Elmo
gets scared of the dark that's why Elmo
has a robot NightLight anytime Elmo
feels scared or or nervous or has any
big feelings Emma's friends T him to do
belly breathing look at
this yeah it always helps Elmo feel
really relaxed and calm El almost so
calm now what's
Elmo's goldfish name oh Elmo's goldfish
is named Dorothy yeah she's the best
sweetest goldfish a moner could ask for
you know Elma fed her this morning yeah
as she went
which means thank you and hello what's
Elmo favorite song oo favorite song
that's really difficult because we sing
so many wonderful songs on Sesame Street
but Elma would have to say his favorite
song is wait for it it's going to shock
you you have no idea this is coming
ready Elmo
song la la la la la la la la Elmo song
you know what El loves about it you
could put anybody's name in there like
Justine we can do la la la la la la la
la Justine song it's adaptable okay
Justine what's the next one how many
fingers does Elmo have does the thumb
count I count it okay Co one two three
four fingers high four high four yeah
how did Elmo mhm get his name well Elmo
got his name from his Mommy and Daddy
they told Elmo that his name means love
and Elmo loves that so Elmo guesses that
Elmo Elmo's that is Elmo a
monster well of course elma's a monster
look see Elmo has red monster th
everybody knows that Elmo's a Monster
Elmo I just heard you're a
monster
congratulations almost everybody knows
come on what I want to show everybody
else that you're a monster does Elmo
have a New York accent well Elma doesn't
think so Elma just kind of sounds like
Elmo Elma doesn't think it's a New York
accent that would be like um hey Elmo's
walking here let Elmo get a slice of
pizza coffee light and sweet that's not
how Elmo sounds does Elmo love me oh of
course Elma loves you oh and Elma loves
you too Miss Justin come down here for a
hug I'm K say I'mma L you without a hug
she has a face isn't that amazing that's
just it W oh what does Cookie Monster
actually ear what what that word ear
what Cookie Monster actually ear oh eat
oh well actually
uh
cies and uh pretty much everything else
yeah and you know it not have to be food
we once ate a truck in not picky eater
next question nicely pulled what is
Cookie Monster's job oh me uh
professional monster oh me also work on
foodie truck you yet a side gig oh no oh
now me never going to know question
maybe me could
help do do what does Cookie Monster like
to do well me got a little bit of tape
on me thank you oh well you know me
well-rounded monster yeah most people
think that all we do is eat cookies but
no we like to uh read books about
cookies paint picture of cookie or say
poem about cookie not all about eating
cookies Who's Cookie
Monsters what is it oh best friend uh's
your best friend oh well yeah well it
could be Abby me have so many for Elmo
Grover Justine in the running uh oh boy
um it uh uh you know what they all me
best friends what Cookie
Monster taught us about selfcontrol oh
boy we going deep now ah yes me do
struggle with um self-control issues yes
but um we have strategies that we like
to use you know like me could uh see a
cookie that there and instead of just
going after it me could sing a song or
uh me could take a deep breath or you
know hug myself that all ways to help uh
with self-control or delayed
gratification as we say it in the
business does Cookie
Monster have a family of course me have
family yeah me got uh mommy and daddy oh
and we got cookie yeah we get to babysit
and you know make cookies together yeah
we love me family maybe you could come
over for a family reunion I would love
to you in is Abby kadabi am I a fairy
what am I a Fairy come on the
wings the magic wand plus oh my goodness
my love for animals and nature and art
and music well I'm 100% fairy what does
Abby kadabi like to do I like to play
with my friends and um oh I like making
up silly stories about hedgehogs and
grow pumpkins in my garden and visit my
fairy tale friends and I love making
glitter
jars see that you just shake it up when
you have big feelings and then you watch
the glitter swirl around and as it
settles down it calms your body down I
love glitter jars what is Abby kadabi
known for probably my magic yeah I do a
lot of magic and my great singing
skills
who is Abby kabi's best friend Ah that's
easy all my friends are the best is
Grover from Sesame Street a cat a cat
why would anyone think that do people
not know that I am a monster oh look at
that cute little kitty cat oh you're so
cute look at you you know what this
feels so good your name whiskers I'm
just going to play along with it
oh
cute as
a can Grover from Sesame
Stree I bet that's a street jump rope
can a fish play the fiddle can an egg
tap dance yes of course I can jump rope
imagine a rope if you
will see look at me jump this imaginary
rope who
whoa oh the imaginary rope made me
realistically fall does Grover from
Sesame Street have toes uh well let us
see let us find out shall we
together all right yeah looks like I
have toes on this foot I have toes on
this foot as well yes indeed Grover does
have toes
W just need a leg to stand on I guess
does Grover from Sesame Street Play oh
well I love to play games yes all kind
of games I oh
instruments well I love to play
instruments as well
yeah I can play them
all yeah just not very
well keep it up I'm loving this okay
Miss Justine let's see what's the next
question what breed of dog is Tango from
Sesame Street Tango is is brave like a
like a
beagle yes
and smart like a terrier and very fluffy
like a
pole I'm that Tango is also part Cookie
Monster cuz she loves to eat can Tango
from Sesame Street fly can Tango
fly now why Tango from Sesame Street
with Elmo my Elmo really loves Tango you
know when Elmo takes care of Tango and
plays with Tango
there's no better P than a monster and
this
doggy can Tango from Sesame Street
dance let's see dance
tango oh yes so I'm supposed to answer
these questions
huh these right here all right what in
Oscar the Grouch trash can first of all
I just have to say I love this grammar
what's in my trash can I got lots of
stuff it's pretty messy I got trash of
course then there's a a swimming pool
for my pet elephant fluffy an old
bowling alley a piano and that's just my
first floor why is Oscar the Grouch so
grumpy now this is a good question
simple cuz I'm a grouch it's in my
nature now can we get to the next
question how long do I have to sit here
for huh how did Oscar the Grouch turn
green well it is true I used to be
orange then I went on vacation to swamp
mushy muddy there was so much mck and
green moss there when I came back I
looked like this a nice Hue of muuk what
makes Oscar the Grouch happy happy but
why are you searching for that huh on
principle us grouches try to be in a
constant state of unhappiness yes I will
say though my head does perk up at the
smell of trash in the morning that was a
lot of fun wasn't it cookie we done yeah
it's all over oh me guess we don't need
this
anymore
everybody want some no thank
you